ho fatto tre o quattro video sul player
non batte il grande ma non ho mai fatto
un video da solo perché io ho sempre
giocato con gli altri internamente via
registrazione qua barca lacca questi
youtuber tutti i tecnologie e quindi
stavolta giochiamo solo io e voi
ok mi seguite in questa avventura
incredibile così vi spiego anche un po
come funzionali storici gioco spesso è
il nuovo registro mike è veramente [ __ ]
sia complimenti per il make up
segui tutorial di clio cioè una freccia
sulla testa non si è resa conto
l'obiettivo ragazzini mai arrivare primi
quindi sopravvivere a tutte le 98
persone che su torino ci è caro stato
taglia gli all in aria smania fogliani
altre devono vai andranno tutti i
ragazzi bruciavano nel culo pedante
nessuno ha uno solo
sapete che vi dico io vado a fare il
culo a quell'unico cristiano che è
caduto con me perché sono una persona
stronza vediamo se il car nani punisce
il carnet è una [ __ ] vedere qua
dentro se c'è qualcosa va dove la porta
della porta del recinto
non so che vi conviene treni vicini di
casa ragazze macchina lo prendo avendo
questo brand lo prendo si va là
bene anche tanto proprio
e vabbè quanto caprino
finalmente mi sento tipo willy il coyote
quando spiava beep beep
questo potrebbe essere considerato
stalking a casa mia la mia prima vittima
di oggi l'offerta com'è possibile allora
se si restringe l'area e quindi definire
forte ricordo che cosa sta facendo
esattamente non lo capisco perché si sta
avvicinando la parete elettrica quindi
verrà per forza verso di me sono
schianta eccolo lì porca vacca che porta
in testa problema è che non posso andare
a prendere le cose che aveva perché
leggermente lontano e polita persone
investito dalla parete elettrica non
istigati da un farmi ben page
la cosa che non ho capito è come il
dialogo sono arrivati 15 ha chiuso fatto
che serve stato arrestato bellissima
salivoli editrice rembado se mi spara
insomma incarto dai meter button ea chi
l'incredibile in 11 dai dai dai dai dai
dai gatto ragazzo ho lasciato la
macchina ho ricavato a dove la donna di
cure da judith allora la zona figura è
qui mica io sono troppo indietro ci sono
i must in dieci aree pochissimo porca
vacca che fastidio guardalà c'è una
macchina di qualcuno non so il problema
di quando il cerchio ecodistretto raga
che non so da che parte possono essere
ovunque tipo lei mi chiamino di macchine
in giro record è che questa acqua chiama
carta si sono state calmi e madonna che
kakà che kakà 18 sono rimasti tecnici
preteso rimasti perfetto se io riesco a
27 il mio numero
non posso maria adesso riusciti a
il grigio per terra ci per terra ma non
mi sono scoperto come la morte sono per
andare a una di queste rocce del micro
ad otto fortissimo io parlo mi chiamate
che fa l'altro di cure dalla parte
opposta di dove sono io ma che invece
qualcuno lì in mezzo agli alberi e sto
aspettando che mi muovere spararmi testa
ricurvo sono aspetti e dai parà li devo
farcela stavolta no all e non alla
capitale litro sforando mica che fu
incredibile dai dai dai vecchio vecchio
come quello verso destra può
sorprendersi minchia quanto sono gli
occhi ricamate kakà assurda dov'è la
gente visto riguardava detto secondo me
qualcuno c'è a destra non posso
infilarmi in mezzo all'erba nostro
quadretti di questo qua minchia quattro
live dove siete
il cerchio è piccolissimo dove sono sti
4 set i 3 il 4 sono io una sicura là
dentro c'è dentro la carta di ficcare
addosso pure l'uso di vendita integrando
dopo della nuova casacca quanto medi
medico sti quattro militi strappando sta
sparando qui si sono visti i che è
un'ottima cosa per me perché fossero un
video 3d che sono la casa sicuro che
sono la causa sicuro che sono a casa
varia devo muovermi che cerchiate arriva
uno forse l'ho visto ma era anche con un
pezzo di erba perché con fondo l'erba
con la gente ah ecco perché io di qua un
nuovo eccolo lo visto rito sposi di un
po caotico g volevi due ragazzi uno
contro uno
la pinar e ragazzi giochiamo qua la fina
26 testa il culo dove si chiariscono
grande dov'è il tizio da questo solo 26
dove vado
l'opera ma troverà secondo dai
cheppallle dai uno contro uno porca
[ __ ]
[Musica]
la ragazza ha fatto perché che la sketch
un agente va bè ragazzi volete vedere la
guerra vera e quella nera via militari e
bene ci va anche mia nonna qua ma
lavorare con la mia nonna che è caduta
su tavola tela gente potrebbero essere
picciò di no però non sono picciotti
sono teste di culo separano fottermi le
armi ma non riusciranno ad un'altra foto
manoscritto fare a cazzotti con il primo
è lo sapevo io
porca vacca marshall in altro punto 3 ma
cosa vuoi da mia vita ma vedrai subito
guerra addio di due un'apertura parti
centro da destra quindi le cose qua
sinistra si sta avvicinando la porta
adesso a meno mai più trova i pugni
[Musica]
quanti spari aiuto ai una dokic sparando
via via via tra l'arma schifosa spendo
fatti avanti la madonna ho visto ma che
dovrà essere abbastanza nesso bene
perfetto ottimo posto alla guida mi
sparate basta a spararli eva per tutti
dove mi interesso tizio era che non lo
prendo la patente scusate io non sono
capace di fare un mix porca vacca the
fastidio che siete madonna dado lei mi
spari ad essa del volo allora eccolo lì
per giocare giochiamo vieni qua per
penso io non l'abbia visto che per il
culo una scarica di proiettili faccia
canta i rambo
occorre rifare il filo mi ha quasi
ucciso tra l'altro è rimasto con tanto
così non ho mai fatto star o da persona
prima devo farlo perché il gas e sta
arrivando è a dai vigili barca da
quattro soldi sono dei ripari in teoria
però mai mai mai vecchio wagon e coupé
vengono recuperi lo dice lo spinge ma
davanti però fisco campi del parco i
corner o minore punto fuori chiamata
ragazzi con una macchina sono martino
estratto succedendo è che tali a
riguardo tempo ma donna contenente il
mio personaggio di io canto milano in
carriola mai più veloce la macchina era
diana ok non ho mai fatto sta roba non
apro medio ora ce l'ha fatta
ci ho messo una vita e mezza
voglio fare una cosa che non so se
funziona la parola detto vai vai ma ci
provo
perché io in fondo la patente un po mela
merito
[Musica]
a costo di una traversa e questo ponte
questo qui secondo me si fanno un culo
enorme perché se ci riesco questo
momento è abbastanza bene perché vado
tipo qui dovete alzare le mani al cielo
tipo glock per darmi la porta riuscirà
questa cosa perché non si aprono altro
ciclo mai dal telo sottoponte maledetto
oggi sparano fortissime somma
per i fiori entrare in una lista casa
sono questo benissimo però che non ci ha
portato mister incastra [ __ ] sarà a
chi in un punto bruttissima dove possono
fare non seconda all'altro e milano
vabbè lasciamo perdere non ho sparato
forte però non mi hanno beccato vita io
vado in quella dopo
no da the fall non venire qua di qua dai
raga al momento della verità e questo
marchio us modo poco
no lo sapevo lo sapevo io dietro tutti
dietro porta tutti mi sento un vago
l'alito risento madonna 1 down fischiano
davanti che non ci spariamo un tesoro
dietro da dietro va bene vabbè ragazzi
basta
ma basta perché ciò un abbattendo
anch'io quindi relatori maria che anche
a ridosso di domenico durare dispiace
dover tv piede ci vediamo seguito spa
sito sito
[Musica]
avanti
fra
[Musica]
nando
io tutto